Okay, so let's go ahead and get going with the exercise for this course.
In this case, I've opened up the map in one of the projects that was given to you
as part of this course. So if you go and open up your Lumen project,
and you go to Lumen example, and open up the map, you should be able to see the same thing
I'm seeing here. Now, before I do anything, I wanted to go over all the light types that we
have in Unreal Engine to show you how they work individually, as well as some of the details
that are more general about lighting in general. So in order to do this, what I'm going to do is
just delete all the lights that are here, and I'll do one by one, and sort of take a look at them.
So I'm going to delete the two skylights and direction lights here, and you can see
we're going to complete darkness, except for these emissive materials, which are contributing
to the Lumen scene, as we mentioned earlier in the slides. So let's start with the first
light here. I've gone to the Place Actors tab and gone to the lights, and I'm going to
start with the first light, which is the direction light. So I'm just going to drag that in,
and you can see it already does the work of a direction light. So this is one of the
main lights. It's essentially going to work like your sunlight or your moonlight. Now, I can rotate
or move, but in this case, for the direction light, moving doesn't make a difference because
it's a bunch of parallel rays emulating the sun. But in the case for the direction light,
rotating is going to be your friend in terms of getting the shadows that you want.
Let's go ahead and do a pretty low light and get some shadows on the wall here. And the reason I'm
trying to get some shadows on the wall is just because it'll help us play around with some of
the features. So here we go. We have our lights up. And importantly, if we're going to work with
Lumen, it's better to have our lights as movable. So on every light type that you use,
or every static mesh as well, you will see here the mobility of the actor. Now, in our case,
as I say, we want this to be movable, so we'll set that to movable. And there you have it. Now,
with all lights, we have things like the intensity values or the color of the light
that we can change. For example, if we wanted to make this a little bit more orange,
we could infuse a bit of orange light in there. We could also change the intensity,
leave that at 10, as well as some other properties like the indirect light and intensity,
so how much it contributes to indirect lighting, for example. We'll leave these at one. And one
of the nice tricks about the direction light that I wanted to show you is that if you're trying to
soften your shadows up, the source angle here is the value you're trying to find. So if I drag
this up, you'll notice that my shadows become much nicer and softer. So depending on the type
of scene that you're trying to get, you might want different values there. But in our case,
as I say, source angle here, working to give us some nicer, softer shadows.
That's the direction light. It's a pretty straightforward one. We go to the next one,
which is a point light. When I drag the point light in, you can see it works the same way
if you're familiar with any other DCC packages. It works the same as an omni light. So it's a
light that from one point releases in all directions. So there we have it. Once again,
we're going to want to set this to movable. And in this case, we can move and rotate this
light. And the settings here are going to be the same. You can change the light color.
The attenuation radius will determine how far that light travels from that point.
And the intensity will determine the intensity of the light. You have, once again, some common
options like the indirect light intensity. So again, how much it contributes to that bounce
light in the scene. And again, this is all being handled automatically and dynamically
by Lumen, which is really, really nice. No need to bake or anything like that.
So next we have the spotlight, which would work exactly as you'd expect.
Now, spotlight has a couple of interesting things that we can take a look at.
First of all, we have an inner and outer cone angle. So the outer cone angle
will determine how wide the cone of light that you're emitting from that spotlight is.
So let's go ahead and put it against this wall here so we can see it a little bit better.
So you can see as I change the cone angle to how that affects the shape of the light,
I can just change the inner cone angle to change the fall off of the strength of that light.
So I'm just going to press G to go into game mode here so we can see that
happen in real time. You can see that adjust the fall off.
And then we also have the source radius, which essentially determines a little bit in the same
way that the source angle on the directional light determines the softness of the shadows.
We can get the same sort of effect when it comes to spotlights and point lights
changing the source radius. So this essentially changes the
size of the light bulb, if you will, and will make for softer shadows, but also
bigger specular reflections, essentially, because it has to take into account the size of the
light bulb of the reflection. So that's another thing to keep in mind.
Next, we have rect light or rectangular light, which is really, really useful light.
And it has a couple of quirks of its own as well. So once again,
changing the size of the source will make the shadow softer, but in this case,
it also changes the shape of the light significantly.
So let's go ahead and take a look at the rectangular light here.
So I could change the length and the width, and you can really see how that affects
the shape of the light in this case. And as the name suggests, you know,
they're rectangular lights. And importantly, we also have the band or angle.
So that's how steep the angle of the shape of the light that's actually getting shot out.
And you can really help you sharpen up or essentially change the properties of the way
in which the light's coming out. So the light is propagating out of this point here.
And you can imagine this shape being essentially a piece of geometry that's
affecting the propagation of that light. So that's the rectangular light.
Once again, we also have typical values here, changing color, intensity,
indirect lighting, as well as the attenuation. So how far that light travels from that spot.
And last but not least, we have the skylight, which you probably use in most of your scenes,
which allows for the calculation of that global contributions to the indirect lighting
in the global illumination and sky shadowing as well. Again, I'm just going to set that to
movable, like we've been doing with all the lights. And once again, in this case,
you've got light color, indirect lighting intensity, and the intensity of the light itself.
Let's go ahead and set it to 9.4. So the last thing I wanted to take a look at,
because we've looked at most of the lights, is these two different light setups. Now,
these two light setups are actually plugins that we've enabled. And they essentially come with a
few extra bonuses. They're not just a straight up light type. So I'm going to drag the HDRI
backdrop in here. And you can see it's a blueprint that includes an HDRI backdrop
and comes with a skylight already. So you can put your model in here and take the screenshots.
Now, the cool thing about this is that, as you can see already, the HDRI backdrop is actually
contributing to the light and scene. Importantly, if you want to change that HDRI backdrop,
you can change it here under the cube map section. You can also change its intensity,
just like you'd imagine with all the other lights. However, the color will be determined
by the cube map that you end up using. So no direct color changes. So that's the HDRI
backdrop. The next thing is the sun and sky, which essentially is a blueprint that accurately
mimics the sun and sky positions for a particular location and time on Earth.
So if I have this, you'll notice that it blooms our screen out completely,
and that's because it has a default value for the direction light that comes with it to 75,000
lux. So in order for us to adjust to this, we need to change the exposure on our scene.
So to do that, I'm going to go to the Lit tab here, or the View Mode tab. And instead of
having the exposures at the game settings, I'm going to untick that,
and I'm going to manually drag this up until it makes a little bit more sense for us.
Now that I've done that, we can take a look at the blueprint itself, and you'll see
it's got quite a lot of interesting things. You can choose a latitude and longitude
for somewhere in the world, adjust the time zone for it, and then choose the date,
and it will accurately mimic the lighting on that time of day, on that date,
in that specific latitude and longitude. So really good if you're trying to make a more accurate
simulation of what something might look like in a particular location. And again, this is actually
something that's really handy for the architecture and construction industries, for example.
Let's go ahead, and I'm going to undo those changes until we get our lights back,
which we do. And I'm going to go back to our game settings. Let's go ahead and delete
the HDRI backdrop. And those are the two, as I say, more advanced lighting setups that
really are just blueprints that are set up to have particular properties.
The last thing I want to take a look at, because we are looking at luminatheral,
is the contribution to the lighting from emissive materials. So as you can see here,
this light here has a material, and if I open it up, we'll open up the parent, you'll see it
has emissive color assigned to it. So this value here is actually shooting past the value of
one and emitting light itself. So if we wanted to create an object that was glowing and
contributing to the lighting, let's say for example here, all we need to do is, for example,
drop down, search for a material that has some glow on it, and assign it. And you can see,
as soon as we do that, that material is already contributing to the global illumination of the
scene. So that's it for our light types and a general simple introduction to the lighting
tools inside Unreal Engine 5. I hope you enjoyed.